I'm going to give it a short class.
What is known as a short class.
The,
uh,
they call it,
it's an old idea,
used to call it the Lexia bravest shop class.
So I just want to give you a little introduction to what the courses will be
like and,
and,
uh,
an introduction also about the context of,
within which Dante thrives.
Dante grows and [inaudible] writes this poem of his,
a poem there is,
you know,
it's called the divine comedy.
It's not really the title Dante gives to the poem.
Dante call the poem.
Simply comedy divine is the,
the,
the adjective the epithet that readers in through centuries have assigned to it
to indicate both what struck the message brime quality with techs and also the
content it deals after all,
the fundamental theme of the poem is the encounter of a pilgrim and northern
remain who you'll see lived,
uh,
the 13th century,
14th century,
uh,
and who imagines this journey to God.
So it's divine also because of this particular content.
It's the,
it's a journey.
It's,
it's uh,
it's a quest for nothing less than seen God face to face and come back to talk
about it now.
Just seeing God and be overwhelmed by it dazzled by it as probably is the,
uh,
what we know.
And it's most of the,
the tradition about visionary literature.
This is really about writing the poem about this fundamental experience will be
reading this poem.
And if I had to give you something of a genre,
it's a very difficult to speak of genres.
They said an epic.
Is it auto biography?
Is it a romance?
I think it's all of the things above.
It's all of these things.
And probably the best way to talk about it is there.
It is an encyclopedia.
What does the word mean?
The word means a circle of knowledge.
It's an old classical idea.
Uh,
it was made,
I could tell you it was made available enough times in the,
in,
by an architect by the name of vitriol,
views,
roads actually.
Uh,
and it talked about integral pedia.
It really means this,
as I said,
the circle of knowledge in the sense that to know you have to have a point of
departure and at that point of departure will take you along all the various
disciplines of uh,
uh,
the so called liberal arts.
And then they take you right back to where you started the beginning and the end
in a liberal education,
we'll have to coincide.
You are going to find out things that now you will see with a different view
from a different standpoint.
The difference perspective.
Dante writes an encyclopedia,
uh,
which also means an ordering of the tradition of exactly the so called liberal
arts.
What are the liberal arts,
why are they call liberal?
They're called liberal to distinguish them from the so called mechanical arts.
This is an old medieval distinct and they're called liberal also because the aim
of this art is to free us.
It's as if knowledge has in itself the power to give us some kind of freedom,
free us from all sorts of,
uh,
some various source of tyranny.
That tyranny of action above all the theory of having to do things with your
hands that will distract you from the great aims and break their hams.
Har Theory,
contemplation,
uh,
thinking.
So the liberal arts,
what are these liberal arts,
the liberal arts I saw called the arts words that distinguish them between arts
of words and arts number.
The Arthur wards are the,
the,
the grammar fundamental which encompasses also poetry and history.
They are a dialectics and rhetoric rhetoric,
Thea to persuasion,
the electrics being the art of
deciding what the truth of the statement.
Maybe it's a little,
it was difficult of this art and then there are the arts of numbers.
There are some numbers or let me take geometry.
Music based on rhythm or number and then astronomy.
The aim of this liberal arts would be ethics.
It would be also a theology,
metaphysics and theology.
This is the way the divine comedy is actually structured.
This,
I'm going to show you as we are going to read this poem.
The implication of calling the divine comedy and encyclopedia is that clearly it
deals with education.
You cannot have an encyclopedia.
You Do,
you know,
you,
you do have the answer Copia Britannica,
which gives you all the possible in interesting,
important items provided in a very disconnected way according to the laws of the
alphabet.
But the aim of the encyclopedia is really to educate the reader.
So Dante actually shows in this sense,
it's an autobiography.
The poem is not aware of it shows the process,
but which he comes to know the world around him.
So we are going to talk about things that have to do with,
with politics.
I have to do with,
uh,
questions that aren't racist all the time.
What is justice in the world?
How do the claims of justice,
uh,
go along with the realities of,
of,
of passions,
the conflicting,
the collusion of conflicting desires,
conflicting parties and so on.
But also we'll be talking about ethics,
uh,
agency,
you know,
and my,
uh,
do I know things and because I know things,
I'm all right or I had my problems a little bit different because my wheel is
really weak.
It's an old idea,
the weakness of the wheel.
Um,
and if I know what I should be doing,
we all know we shouldn't be just,
that doesn't really make us just right.
Uh,
we have,
we're the,
the,
uh,
kind of frailty and vulnerability to wanting to do things that we normally
shouldn't be doing.
And we even know that we shouldn't do that.
We'll talking to resist some of these issues,
uh,
in a very lucid and I think the most probing manner possible.
And then he goes on,
uh,
writing this point,
which is,
as you know,
written about going into hell,
literally,
uh,
and trying to rectify the belief that you can really get out of it and,
and,
and rearrange the older your vision about the world and about yourself.
Every time you talk about ethics and every time you talk about,
about politics are real.
Question is,
who am I and what am I doing in order to come to some kind of understanding of
the world around myself.
So we'll,
we'll be talking about some of these issues in detail and reading in a very,
um,
and assuming way without any or all the various cantos that are indicated in
your,
in the syllabus.
But let me go to the other part,
which is really probably the most concrete part.
This is,
I gave you the general scheme of the,
of,
of the lectures.
Let me just talk about,
uh,
the concrete context of Dante's
life contour of his life.
Who is this man?
How did he end up writing a poem that seventh centuries or more after he wrote
it?
It's still red.
The still be thought of as one of the major contributions that a human being can
make to our culture.
Um,
well he was born as you know,
probably
in a
16,
I'm sorry,
two 1265,
uh,
1265 in a city called Florence Act that are by the time Dante was of school age
had 70,000 people,
7,000.
These are little details to impress you about how crucial or important that's
it.
What was 7,000 boys and girls who go to school.
Public schools were available to them.
Dante was one of these people.
He,
he was born in a,
um,
in a family that was somehow,
uh,
he claimed the,
an nobility and a whatnot,
but actually it was an impoverished family and he was even a slightly
embarrassed by the activities of his own father.
He never mentioned him,
but we do know by poems others had written against him,
attacking him and attacking his genealogy,
accusing the father of,
uh,
low and being involved in loan and the kind of,
usually,
um,
activities a usurer,
uh,
lending money or high,
very high interest,
uh,
and so on.
When he,
Dante,
two events happened to him.
Private events happened to him when he was a child.
The first is by the time he was eight years old,
his mother died
and the second a little bit connected with it.
It's the fact that when he was nine years old,
he will tell us later.
He met a young woman.
He doesn't even know what her name is.
That's the fiction of,
of his own work.
He knew because she actually was a neighbor.
He calls her,
uh,
Beatrice,
the way he goes on transferring all the love that he felt a wanted from his
mother owned to this young woman.
Uh,
we don't know it unless we're just involved in some kind of second political are
speculations about his life,
the facts.
We don't know.
However,
he does talk about her as if she were a mother to,
to him.
He describes her in the poem in very maternal language and the language of her
great generosity,
the generosity of love actually.
So these are the two events.
And then he goes to school in,
uh,
in Florence and the school for all these teachers.
He'd have only one that he really will point out and we'll remember forever.
Amen.
By the name of Brunetto.
Latini.
We'll see him later in hell.
I like money out of students.
They don't want to send a teacher to her,
but not you of course.
But this,
this was,
he does,
he manages.
Who was this man?
Why was he so important for,
for Dante?
Well,
great authority.
We could call him.
Um,
he still talked about if you ever have happened to go to Florence and you read
this,
uh,
a student will come kind of memorial stones that are all everywhere on the walls
of the city.
He was one of those who civilize the city of the city of Florence.
Where was he do and what did he do actually?
Well,
he was Eric tuition,
first of all,
in the mode of CIS Heronian.
This is a rolling tradition.
Every tradition is to say a woman who believed that politics and rhetoric go
hand in hand.
That rhetoric is the art of persuasion within the,
the,
the parliament within the city streets of the city.
Uh,
uh,
where large decisions can be made that can be reached.
This was the essential work of brutality,
play styles himself after [inaudible].
It was not only a great teacher,
he actually translated our end commented works that we have by Cicero on
rhetorical works,
Cicero,
uh,
in the belief that really the political problems are ultimately problems have
speech problems of arguments.
Uh,
but he also was a traveler.
He went to,
uh,
we do know that he went to Toledo.
They city of Toledo in Spain.
Uh,
he did bring in a translations,
uh,
of,
even even a very realistic Texas.
I will explain all this terms as we go on.
Uh,
[inaudible] admires him,
especially because he stands for the salt of teacher who gets involved in
political,
the political realities of Florence.
Dante wants to follow him in that.
Eventually he would meet Beatrice again.
A writes a great poem inspired by her,
which we'll be looking at next time,
called the Vita Nuova.
Uh,
the teacher,
his teacher Burnet Talatine will die and Dante decides to enter.
We are already,
uh,
1290 decides to enter political life himself.
It was his biggest mistake.
It was his biggest mistake because political life in Florence really meant being
in the throes of a harsh partisan battles between the so called Welsh and give
balance.
The,
the issues are not so clear cut.
The world supposedly are those who really believe in,
uh,
the,
the loyalty to the church.
Uh,
the others that gibberish,
those who believe in the loyalty to the empire.
Uh,
the two institutions at the time,
things are not that clear cartels as,
as that the sharply separable as that.
We'll talk about some of the details about,
about this,
but Dante becomes an ambassador for the city of Florence,
the way Brunette had become an ambassador for the city of Lawrence.
And he goes a little bit everywhere.
He sent to the pope in the year 1302,
he sent to the pope on an embassy and he never makes it back to Florence.
Machinations had taken place so that he would be banned from the city,
not only been from the city,
his,
his properties confiscated.
And there is the threat on him,
uh,
that should he return and should he get caught,
he would actually be put to death.
The year 13.
Oh two is the beginning of Dante's new education and new experience.
He goes into exile and exile,
which at the time was thought to be a nothing less then,
uh,
the fiercest condemnation on anybody because we are,
that's the,
the medieval idea.
We are the,
the,
the value of each and every one of us depends on the position that we occupy
within the city.
To be without sat,
not be a holder of a place within the city means that one is actually nothing.
So he goes literally begging from one city to another,
maybe even traveled as far as,
as,
as Paris.
We don't know that,
but exile though it turned out to be a harsh punishment,
turned out to be also nothing less than a blessing,
a blessing in disguise because it,
it removed Dante from any sense of loyalty to partisan viewpoints.
He was no longer,
uh,
he was no longer to be a wealth or a GIB Berlin.
He was no longer caught in this internecine wars.
He now became nothing less than one or could occupy a transcendent viewpoint.
This is what the story of the divine comedy is.
How does one go from perceiving the world that aren't oneself in this partial
provisional,
fragmentary manner?
How can one be pulling it together?
And the divine comedy is the story of exile being the removal oneself from the
city in order to best see what the problems with the cities.
And uh,
he ended his life in the year 13,
21 in a city called Ravenna where he was buried.
Uh,
so that's the way he wrote the poem,
uh,
was in exile.
The poem came out of this experience of exile.
He begins his life as an example,
but I think the philosophical text called the banquet in the tradition of,
uh,
of work,
the title of the Symposium Right now on ethics,
he abandons his project,
starts a project on language trying to find a unified,
the possibility of unifying all the languages.
Italy writes a political texts about the necessity of unifying the world with
this empire.
The monarch finishes that.
But the real process of unification of all these experiences really is with the
divine comedy.
And we'll be reading that,
uh,
in,
in a couple of,
a couple of days.
That's all I have to say to you is if there are some questions and then I'll try
to,
uh,
and those,
yes.
What is the question again?
The final paper is due within two weeks of the end of classes.
The question was,
when is the final paper due?
Okay.
How important is
the knowledge of the Italian language?
How important this,
the,
the knowledge of Italian language,
the courses all in English.
We are reading a translation with the original text,
uh,
by the side.
Um,
if you can read it in the Italian good.
If you want to write the paper and Italian,
you're welcome to do so.
But the course is going to be,
we are treating the poem as if it were in,
uh,
in England and English poem.
After all,
someone says,
[inaudible] is an American poet.
Uh,
and we could explore that tool.
Other questions?
Okay.
Hey,
we'll see you on Tuesday.